hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well Emmanuel Kant begins his Preamble
on the peculiarities of metaphysical
cognition in his proma to any future
metaphysics with a
methodological question about
metaphysics as a science as a visen
shaft as a type of cognition in general
and he tells us that if we want to know
what a science is we need to be able to
differentiate it from the other scienes
and he says all right so how do we
typically make distinctions
differentiations or create differentia
if we want to use the latinate term and
he's actually using uh two different
very closely related German terms onid
then uh and uh Onida right so we've got
the things that are the differences
literally the split apart from each
other or distinguished and what are what
are differentiating right and then he
talks about peculiar features
a the things that are specific to a
particular science that it has and other
Sciences don't and some of these will be
shared by others if you know for example
he's going to say you know there's some
degree of similarity between mathematics
and metaphysics in this respect in this
respect right and we'll get to that in
just a bit so the peculiar features he's
going to single out three of them
differences that we can find in the
object and the German term there is just
the object right so no need to like put
the German here uh on the the board uh
and the object is going to be well it's
kind of unclear could be the point of it
the zve as he's going to talk about
later on the end the goal or it can be
the sort of things that it's dealing
with as its particular matters and then
he talks about sources of
cognition is Source or literally spring
uh a Kess cognition knowledge right so
where is it actually
getting I'm going to make a little pun
here it's ideas its Notions its Concepts
from using those terms in kind of a
broad sense and then we can also talk
about the kind
of cognition the type ER art right the
art is the kind or you might even
sometimes see that translated as species
right but I think kind or type works
just fine for this and he doesn't treat
these in the order that he presents them
he begins by talking about the sources
of cognition and what does he actually
tell us well he says it's very concept
the very concept of
metaphysics implies that the sources
cannot be empirical it's principles he
says must never be derived from
experience and that's what we mean by
empirical or empira in in the German
that he's writing right it's not coming
from our experience of the world outside
or even our experience within because
that is going to yield us merely uh you
know all sorts of sensory things and
then psychology which is not the same
thing as metaphysics so he says it must
not be physical but metaphysical
knowledge what's the difference between
physical and metaphysical well
metaphysical knowledge lies Beyond
experience the experience of the
physical world so he says it can
therefore have for its basis neither
external experience source of physics
proper nor internal the basis of
empirical psychology so it's a priori
cognition which is coming from Pure
understanding and pure reason and that's
you know what he has derived as he
points out in the critique for critique
of pure reason so those are the sources
and he says if we only look at this that
doesn't actually give us the
differentiation that we want why so far
metaphysics would not be distinguishable
from pure mathematics it should it must
therefore be called Pure philosophical
cognition then he refers us to the
critique of pure reason and talks about
those and then he says so much for the
sources of metaphysical cognition okay
so so far so good we've got one
differentiator but it is not
successfully differentiated metaphysics
from all the other Sciences because it
looks like mathematics has a lot in
common with it okay so now we can go to
the kind of cognition and that's what he
actually Begins the next section with
concerning the kind of cognition ER ARA
which alone can be called metaphysical
and then you might say well it's kind of
weird he's going into this new
distinction between analytic and
synthetic uh what is the difference you
know between all of these well this is
going to play an important role and
we'll talk about that distinction in a
little bit more detail El
where and he's you know looking at where
the the principles of these are coming
from but what's important here is that
he tells us that metaphysical
cognition must consist of and he he's
got two
differentiators here it has to be called
um AR prior judgments right so again not
empirical things that can be understood
apart from from our experience now it's
not as if AR priori uh Concepts
judgments propositions don't have
anything to do with the empirical World
they can be applied to it but they don't
derive from that and then they're also
synthetic judgments and so synthetic
here means that you know if you've got a
subject and a predicate the predicate is
what is being said of the subject
something new is being derived for us in
putting these things together and
interestingly as a side note Kant
actually considers mathematics to be
largely also a priori synthetic
judgments as well so that 5 + 7 equals
12 12 is not contained in 5 + 7 it's
adding something new to our our
knowledge uh we'll talk about that
elsewhere very interesting topic right
and now in terms of this kind of
cognition this is uh coming up in the
little discussion of metaphysical
judgments he says that we have to make a
a further
distinction judgments that belong to
metaphysics G right belonging to uh you
know obeying you could even say uh sort
of you know subsidiary things and
metaphysical judgments properly socalled
I
right so those things that are
authentically or genuinely
metaphysical and he's going to tell us
that um many of the the former the
things that belong to metaphysics are in
fact analytic but they only afford means
to metaphysical judgments which are the
entire aim of the science and which are
always
synthetic so he says if there be
Concepts belonging to metaphysics for
example that is substance
judgments springing from simple analysis
of them also belong to metaphysics for
example substance is that which exists
only as subject and Etc uh and he says
we can use analytic judgments to arrive
at the definition of a concept but the
analysis of a pure concept doesn't
proceed in any different manner from the
dissection of any other even empirical
Concepts so the concept but not the
analytical judgment is properly a
metaphysical and so here we're actually
getting to you know the the question of
object in a moment and he says this
science has something special bous and
peculiar aan tum uh to
itself and uh what is this going to be
production of AR priori
cognitions now I want you to notice
something here a priori not judgments at
this point but cognitions are K so right
and we could say maybe those are
equivalent to each other but we'll we'll
see in just a bit but the production the
of of this is is what is really uh tied
in with the kind of cognition that we're
dealing with and this leads us to the
the object what is what is the point of
metaphysics and what is what does it
work on what we've already got a lot of
that answered right a priori synthetic
judgments or proposition
or cognition and so he goes on and says
if the op prior Concepts which
constitute the materials and building
blocks of metaphysics have first been
collected according to fixed principles
analysis will be of great value so that
tells us what we're we're up to in the
critique and here in the proma right and
he he goes on he
says metaphysics is properly concerned
with uh synthetic AR priori propositions
zet right so propositions expressing a
judgment and utile right uh we shouldn't
see these as opposed to each other and
we could even say the cognitions are
also expressive of you know the the uh
judgment as well right so that's what
metaphysics is going to be concerned
with and this is he says it's end it's
de for which it indeed requires various
dissections of its Concepts so this is
this is he he goes on he says the
generation of operary cognition by
intuition as well as by Concepts that is
a synthetic propositions op prior and
philosophical cognition constitutes the
essential
content of metaphysics another way in
which we could understand object the
inhalt the content now there are two key
issues that I want to bring up that that
you know are not immediately falling
under these object sources of cognition
kind of cognition rubric but which I
think are very important to talk about
at this point so he is not taking for
granted except in so far as he's you
know written the critique of pure reason
that metaphysics is already indeed
possible and he says we need to ask this
question so how is some something that
fits this bill actually Mugi or possible
how can that be developed and he says
you know a lot of people have been you
know producing metaphysics up to this
time but what they're calling
metaphysics isn't really what
metaphysics would be if it is indeed a
science and this has led to all sorts of
other problems in the history of of
human thought so Kant says well that's
because they've not actually used any
transcendental philosophy what people
have called that up to this point also
isn't the real thing and there is a very
important relationship between
metaphysics and
transcendental philosophy which is
indeed what Kant has been doing as his
project right and so he says it may be
said that the entire transcendental
philosophy which
necessarily precedes all metaphysics is
nothing but the complete solution of the
problem here
propounded and that we've hitherto never
had any transcendental philosophy well
what is the problem how are synthetic
cognitions a priori possible which is
what he's going to talk about in the
rest of of this as well so he goes on
and he says um what goes by its name is
properly a part of metaphysics whereas
the former science has first to settle
the possibility of the latter and must
precede all metaphysics so we've got to
do transcendental philosophy first then
we can actually do real authentic
metaphysics which according to K hasn't
been done so he's clarifying a science
that doesn't yet exist as such even
though other things have been called
that and telling us what it peculiar
features would be and drawing out some
very important implications from
that